und jetzt bekommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut
ja ich weiß gar nicht wie genau ich
anfangen soll
aber ich bin ganz spontan eigentlich auf
dieses video thema kommen und zwar bin
ich letztens auch so ein paar youtuber
gestoßen keine ahnung da man plötzlich
alles voll mit jüngeren youtuber nicht
auf jeden fall ein bisschen auf youtube
unterwegs bin ich in letzter zeit
irgendwie öfter wobei ich zurzeit mich
echt frage alter woraus besteht youtube
eigentlich gerade so in den letzten drei
tagen habe ich eigentlich fast nur
videos gefunden wo irgendwelche menschen
auf irgendwelche musikvideos reagieren
oder irgendwelche menschen irgendetwas
zu legen welchen anderen menschen sagen
das war es und dann haben wir halt die
trends auch schon durch auf jeden fall
bin ich einfach auf die idee gekommen ja
alex schau dir einfach mal ein paar
jüngere youtuber an
ich meine jeder fängt mal klein an es
war mir ja eigentlich genauso ich glaube
ich habe mit zwölf oder 13 das erste
video auf youtube hochladen auch wenn
das gar nicht auf diesem kanal war oder
so aber jeder fängt natürlich mal bei
null an und es ist heutzutage würde ich
schätzen fast unmöglich noch ein großer
youtuber zu werden auch wenn es
beispiele gibt die das geschafft haben
aber nur sehr wenige ich denke mal
früher war das echt leichter ich weiß
halt wirklich auch wie hart es ist vor
allem wenn man gerade mal 13 oder 14
jahre alt ist man sieht aus wie 12 ist
noch nicht im stimmbruch und sonst war
es und dann in die schule zu gehen und
zu wissen dass all diese leute die
youtube videos aus schauen und sich zum
teil darüber lustig machen ist
sicherlich nicht das coolste gefühl und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht alex du
schaust jetzt einfach mal ein paar
jüngere mann und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ja alex du schaust jetzt einfach
mal ein paar jüngere deutsche bahn
was die so machen ich habe euch gestern
aufs netz gefragt falls sie mir da noch
nicht folgt folgt mir auf jeden fall mal
auf wenn das neue update übelster
scheiße ist hier sollten wir auf jeden
fall so die jüngsten youtuber die ihr
kennt einfach mal zu stecken ich habe
ziemlich viele videos bekommen
wir schauen uns zusammen mal rein und
ich bin echt gespannt ob wir wieder so
stoßen und das video soll jetzt
natürlich nicht dazu dienen sich darüber
lustig zu machen ich glaube da bin ich
einer der das mit am besten verstehen
kann wenn man sich über so seine
kreativität oder seine leidenschaft die
man dann halten wir 1314 schon auslebt
lustig macht also vergesst es auf keinen
fall ich mein wenn ihr euch jetzt mal
ein video von mir anschauen würde wo ich
14 war
ich glaube da würdet ihr euch auch schon
zum teil über lustig machen
und jetzt kommt ihr ab und zu schon ein
ganz vernünftiges video warum zwar nicht
immer aber manchmal wenigstens etwas so
natürlich aber gar nicht lange
eine sache wollte ich noch nicht sagen
das ist jetzt natürlich auch so ein
bisschen als kleine starthilfe gedacht
deswegen wenn er öfter auf sowas lust
habt lassen dann nach oben dann sehe ich
dass 8000 drin und ja wir schauen uns
jetzt die jüngsten youtuber deutschland
sein und ihr könnt mir natürlich noch
weitere bei instagram zukommen lassen
kein problem
alex w einfach mal kurz abdecken so der
erste youtuber der mir zugeschickt wurde
heißt simon der heißt einfach nur simon
und von simon wurde mir das urlaubs
shopping holz zugeschickt wir schauen
jetzt einfach mal rein simon ich bin
gespannt
und wenn ich so das erste bild schon
sehe ich finde da sieht es ähnlich aus
wie ich früher nur ich hatte etwas
länger habe ja auf jeden fall okay das
video ist wahrscheinlich schon etwas
älter es geht allerdings zehn minuten 32
also das mit der werbung hat sieht man
auf jeden fall schon raus musste blieben
deswegen in diesem video einfach mal
zeigen was ich da sehr an gehabt also
hemmung hat auf jeden fall keine ich
finde dass um ehrlich zu sein auch
wichtig ich meine wenn man schon an die
sache rangeht man sollte sich so am
besten gar nicht versuchen zu verstellen
ich glaube so youtube videos machen
beziehungsweise sich im internet zu
zeigen hat heute auch noch mal eine ganz
andere bedeutung als wenn man schon an
die sache rangeht dann solltest du auch
so natürlich wie möglich sein da kann
auf jeden fall sehr gut reden also das
erinnert mich so ein bisschen an mich
war das einfach ein bisschen 5 minute 57
sonnenbrille
ja also finde ich um ehrlich zu sein
echt gut für das alter ich will jetzt
mal so auf 3 12 oder 13 schätzen wir
schauen uns jetzt einfach mal kurz den
channel an
17.000 133 abonnenten nicht schlecht ich
meine hat gerade mal vor fünf monaten
angefangen und hat auch erst 15 videos
die man jetzt hier sehen kann es macht
ihm wohl doch spaß nicht zu schminken
ich finde sowas eigentlich voll okay ich
meine jeder soll machen was er will hier
sieht man simon ist echt 13
also ich würde sagen schaut man bei
simon vorbei das abo da und gibt dem
jungen mal hier war es aber was haben
wir denn wie ich glaube dass wieder ob
ich mir angeguckt genau 596 likes und
401 discs ich glaube da gehen wir mal
daumen nach oben
dann sieht das schon viel schöner aus
das könnte ja auch mal machen im prinzip
ein cooler typ aber weniger albern dann
ist es super das finde ich ist ein echt
cooler kommentar ich meine man kann
nicht sofort perfekt seinem ersten video
man kann auch nicht nach 100 videos
perfekt sein aber vielleicht eine sache
das unterstreiche ich so ein bisschen so
dieses albert ist auch mal lustig aber
nicht zu viel und an sich kann ich aber
sagen ich finde er macht es gut und
macht weiter so wenn du das siehst was
ich ja denke also so leute wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten video und das
ist von davon war das nochmal auf das
video heißt meine weihnachtsgeschenke
das video wurde mir auch zugeschickt das
heißt meine weihnachtsgeschenke von
julia israel ich würde sagen wir schauen
mal kurz rein ich hoffe natürlich julina
wenn du das jetzt hieß das ist auch okay
ist dass ich mir das video anschauen
nicht dass du gar nicht möchtest dass
das plötzlich so viele menschen sehen
aber da gehe ich jetzt mal nicht mehr
aus sich machen dann via youtube die
falsche plattform für sagen wir fangen
einfach mal angelina zeigt ist trägt
schon wieder video und die glocken
klingelt immer das gleiche so yu li na
park weihnachtsgeschenke aus let's go
denkt ihr euch auch gerade hat die zu
weihnachten de toilette gekommen
bei welcher spülung spritzt das wasser
heute hätte ich mich auch richtig
gefreut hätten wir meine eltern das mal
geschenkt
juli na wo bist du überhaupt ich kann
nicht gerade oben da oben ist ja wir
schauen noch kurz weiter und dann kriegt
juli natürlich auch ein daumen nach oben
von mir richtig mal sie dich gar nicht
dass du eine toilette bekommen hatte und
ich nicht das finde ich schon hart
gemeint also eine toilette hätte ich
auch gerne
molina vielleicht mein kleiner tipp am
anfang man sieht hier fünf minuten 50
geht das video wenn du schon eine
weihnachts geschenke auspackt ich finde
das ist immer so ein video da kann man
immer viel erzählen das kann man auch
mal leicht auf 10 minuten streckenweise
weil dann kannst du gleich vier mal
werbung schalten
das hatte ich auch nur für jungs aber
glaube ich wirklich ohne wirz diese
calvin klein pappe und das war meine
allererste bis ich irgendwann gar keins
mehr benutzt habt ich finde paar firmen
sind überbewertet
ich rieche ja immer gut weiß ich nicht
vielleicht doch nicht also ich muss
sagen julia macht dass meine meinung
auch echt gut hat hier sogar schon 17
tausend klicks gesammelt und jetzt hast
du noch unten nach oben von mir wir
schauen wir vorbei julina würde ich auch
so auf 13 schätzen und sie ist schaffen
wir 1500 abos hast du doch immer
geschafft 2400 jahre also alle kanäle
sind natürlich in der video beschreibung
verlinkt bei dem der euch am besten
gefällt könnte ja gern mal vorbeischauen
bringen auch bei mehreren und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem nächsten youtube
ich glaube dass auch zwölf oder dreizehn
also vielleicht mal kurz das hier ist
die neue kollektion beziehungsweise
cherry kommt jetzt bald raus der webshop
ist natürlich wie immer in der video
beschreibung verlinkt den habe ich
glaube ich auch zweimal zugeschickt
bekommen einfach weil wir dazu
geschrieben wurde
der kommt auch aus der nähe wo du
herkommst also aus der nähe von
bielefeld ob das stimmt oder nicht weiß
ich nicht aber falls ja muss man das
natürlich unterstützen net heißt der fnp
und ich würde sagen ich zeige mich wir
schauen jetzt mal rein
im video ist schon im titel
ich zeige mich und ja darum sollten nur
wünschen knipsten heutigen video gehen
weil ab ihr fehlt auf diesem kanal kein
minecraft bekommen weil minecraft ist
einfach echt langweilig geworden
weißt du was das sehe ich komplett
genauso ich weiß nicht wie man sich drei
stunden lang minecraft am stück angucken
kann ich meine halbe stunde war okay
aber nur bei craft videos das auch gar
nicht mein fall aber ich muss ehrlich
sagen nur minecraft content ich hasse
das ich und ich finde einfach nicht mehr
den spaß an der sache jobs meter
schwimmen möchte ich hab jetzt was mit
der richtigen kamera da machen
also ich muss mal kurz stoppen ich muss
auf jeden fall sagen ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie alt er ist schauen wir gleich
mal nach aber was mir hier echt sofort
auffällt die kamera qualität ist gut der
schnitt ist auch schon echt gut musik im
hintergrund und das wichtigste ist finde
ich halt er kann echt richtig gut reden
und findet so die übergänge weil man
denkt sich immer so die leuten die halt
zu youtube videos machen wie ich zum
beispiel man muss sich ja ab und zu mal
anhören
yao an sich ist das ja kein talent oder
sowas und ich finde das zu sagen ist
eigentlich falsch ich kann zwar diese
aussage verstehen ja das ist kein talent
aber es gibt so viele menschen die das
auch versuchen aber es halt nicht klappt
weil es ist total und authentisch wirkt
also ich finde man muss auf jeden fall
für sowas gemacht sein und das kann sich
nicht jeder einfach dahin setzen und
irgendwas erzählen das soll sich jetzt
auch gar nicht so selbst überzeugt
anhören aber ich finde es gibt halt
leute den kann man zu hören und es gibt
leute da ist es einfach schwer und die
sind dann vielleicht nicht so für diesen
job als youtuber gemacht aber tripps
macht das für sein erstes reallife wie
du richtig gut
philips knips ich denke die ganze zeit
an diese chips diese flip so ich bin das
gerade auf dem channel von flip das war
wirklich ein erstes video 669 aufrufe
ist ja an sich gar nicht mal schlecht
auch schon 2000 abonnenten wenn wir
jetzt wirklich aus meiner nähe kommt
zeit kommt dann abonniere ich dich mal
als abonnent mehr und du kriegst
natürlich auch ein daumen nach oben von
mir hey du siehst aus wie ein bmw und
ein bisschen wie ein mädchen finde ich
eigentlich gar nicht also der erinnert
mich wirklich eins zu eins an mich
damals fast nur dass er besser schneiden
kann als ich am anfang zumindest also an
dieser stelle geht auf jeden fall mal
rüber auf seinem kanal abonniert flips
ist in der video beschreibung verlinkt
ich bin mal gespannt wie viele
abonnenten hat flip
nach diesem video also mache auf jeden
fall weiter so das wird was und ich
hoffe du freust dich durch das waren
jetzt erstmal drei andere youtuber ich
hatte eigentlich noch mehr ausgesucht
aber wir belasten das jetzt erstmal bei
drei starts auf jeden fall man da vorbei
ist wie gesagt alles in der video
beschreibung verlinkt also was hier auf
jeden fall noch mal sagen muss
vielleicht an auch welche von euch wenn
ihr euch denkt ja ich würde auch gern
youtube-videos machen oder so es ist auf
jeden fall sehr schwer
und wenn man dann halt so we live videos
macht das ist nicht immer leicht glaube
das habe ich auch schon öfter mal gesagt
also wenn man dann noch zur schule geht
da solche mal echt respekt vor haben und
an die ganzen leute die vielleicht auch
jemand in der stufe haben oder so der
auf youtube videos macht oder instagram
videos und dafür belächelt wird finde
ich eigentlich ziemlich scheiße ich
meine er ist ja anscheinend deutlich
mutiger ist hier r traut sich das zu
machen worauf er lust hat und ich finde
das sollte man an lehrstellen auch
respekt hier ansonsten war es mit dem
video schaut auf jeden fall mal bei dem
vorbei würde mich sehr freuen
vor allem bei philips zeigt auf jeden
fall ins programm und das wunder
wundervolle neue snapshot ab richtig
geil
wir sehen uns eventuell morgen wieder
ich weiß noch nicht ganz